welcome to this video I'm a bit late
here with this bullet tournament so I'm
liking about three minutes here but no
worries still got a car chances to catch
up if they're a big tournament is
mentioned in one minute at the bullet
hello day OEM let's see reversed and the
reverse the so you know oops blundering
b7 that's not good but okay at least
them I got rid of the light squared
Bishop so i can try to that's very
greedy set up an attack in nigeria
don't worry so much about material what
you get me the most possible piece is
near the king and it looks like I get
some attacking forces here oops i
blundered if we no no ok at least I have
some activity should be for us what I'd
like to do a five unfortunately an easy
to see man what a start that suddenly
was a good attack but I just blundered
Knight f6 mind of 6cm ok oops big oops
but ok nothing nothing terrible happened
fortunately I wanted to take with the
porn but ended up taking with the night
yeah that's a nice position very nice
for wide as my GF I'll possibly coming
and b7 down let's win let's win this
piece just some pants for nothing so I
probably should close the window to tell
out I guess okay the e-file yeah I got
good control you in the position really
no no serious counterclaim
okay my clothes there oh yeah come on
give me games I think I need games in
order to at least have some chance to
catch on fire that's not totally sound
right but ok we need to complicate
matters Joe not great but it's not it's
playable it's a playable position like
to get in shape to 5-under yeah like
that rope to g6 would be nice or g5 also
helpful yep that I don't mind at all
actually this is just a very much better
Bishop on d5 then why'd sufficient here
we go only danger is some
the count to play with the roofs but I
need you to open it up from other pieces
should win rather easily now also have
Queen a5 coming yep still I'm very far
behind him some guys have five five out
of five maybe I should should play a
phone oh this was ok wasn't really
intended but worked yeah that's a quite
risky this whole thing but should be
should be it should be out okay in a
bullet game yeah I can take now but I
hope that I also have some fly of the g
file with root g 8 I does not have queen
age 5 i'm covering that try to try to
use the pins in 95 a dangerous move now
I'll snider three coming then that chick
made somewhere I don't see I still don't
see made
hm
okay I haven't seen a mate but hopefully
this is good enough take here now and
this should be a meadow Quincy to mate
come on there is no defense right now I
know it disconnects great but they only
has a couple of seconds left so it's not
a huge consequence don't be a quick
today here with the mouse okay no bishop
f7 checkmate okay but I want to want a
piece so that's are quite okay
yeah just a piece but I don't get a
quick chat maiden maybe with with this
as possible taking g7 hi come with that
okay I don't really see a quick meet but
here I'm breaking through on the Kings
side Queen f6 now it looks nice Oh h7
probably this is I made right I don't
find the meteor just just blind here but
grin g8 next year this is answers mate
ok so I'm not not far behind I need some
some really quickly show try to get to
the sensitive f2 pond
I think I can do that home yeah it was
okay g3 quindi for so it wasn't a total
gamble hmm start the game can this still
happens him on the server they simply
cannot solve this issue at least I think
that they should more quickly and end
enter game yeah like it's not working
it's not working and then get get get a
new game oops I let's weird here on the
other side but I win a purpose now rod
oh it's totally irritating bishop age
three but now I'm threatening I'm
awaiting you funny funny stuff however
this way I'm catching up here catching
up after the initial loss i affirm names
yeah Stein it's French here I don't know
still sometimes you can't get someone
under coordinated here and loose
material but this is not one of those
cases unfortunately so this looks nice
for white slightly better this end game
type of position yeah and sort of
invaded here with the Rope here quite
nice nothing terrible happening i hope
but it's it looks a bit but we are
it's good he had default check but did
not play it okay so at the end we
finally got an end game that is better
for wider not much but I have this a for
ideas not sure what he's doing is
letting the clock run down and I went he
can probably play King a five and just
stay I hope this was his connection it's
sometimes a bit strange even if you are
clearly not you know it was it was his
connection Wow when the meat I'm
summarized on 110 now is this even
possible ten out of ten okay wow this
looks really really nice already again
he's got before you I can adapt let's
let's play for a direct attack him not
beat around the bush this should be a
good compensation anyway yeah and
creates for maybe this year with Queenie
five but it still should be quite nice
for me
must trade out to meet position where
I've got the ton of pawns yeah this is
to to kill off the g2 bishop yeah I
don't we know I've got five pounds here
five points look at five points against
two nights don't see that every day
quite nice now this has no squares you
should age for this g5 okay let's take a
nap take all those now I'm going I got a
ton of material extra at my blundering
d3 but he didn't did not use this
opportunity yeah it's okay but I'm not
okay now this guy is lost here either
the one who wasn't delete so we're going
to get a quick game come on I can get
something in quickly here with the
h-bond irritating black a shrine phone
for this operation maybe maybe I get in
we should a form yep I get in Bishop
before this that's nice very tricky now
for black to coordinate expenses
could be very nice king of a queen f4
queen bee ate meat is very tough to to
to prevent a queen bee I'd mate cannot
prevent that that's cute now Bishop
piayed can play Bishop you aid it's very
big ugly but this is what is possible
then I can take f8 actually if I want
yeah this was the best decision for me
getting the point quickly Jan that that
was a really bad opening
maybe this helps to irritate him not
really all right okay I get in Bishop h
6 ER this is not too bad preventing
castling okay this is nice now with the
castling impossible should be a nice
position for black yeah this is the
issue quickly quickly breaking through
Quincy one made on a king move 93 I take
f2 yep okay 12 points behind I need a
quick window to then i can actually ever
take that number one place here zurich
meant i lost against the sky i think it
was the first round game that's nice to
get
and okay where's the chip made that's
one of them yep so this is this is first
place with this Goodwin but I still need
to get in a couple of games for sure
it's very very close Oh risky against
you for don't like to play this totally
on some gambits even a bullet I simply
don't play well after them this is my
problem yeah that's a strange setup that
he chose but okay a very very nice
position strategically speaking I just
got the H file so it's not it's not
totally easy
yeah I could have taken on a three but I
wanted to secure my position for us to
make it oh and take a queen this is too
tempting I the queen i will take
definitely yeah unfortunately he does
not resign this no he does that's good
so five minutes left I still need games
yeah come on Knight c3 is a good at a
good pre month maybe again this this
funny line h6 is really tempting
tempting move and losing immediately
that's funny that's exactly the same
game yeah I wouldn't exactly the same
game yeah that's really cute okay very
very useful don't need to think about
this again okay the French I don't know
not the easiest choice it's a good pre
move 26 you can always and always play
that basically no matter what white is
doing a success a playroom
let's get rid of this this dangerous
bishop and the Queen's also would be
nice I stopped doing that so that's a
very nice position against Isis lately
at home don't want to get my crank mated
here of course and now I'm threatening
93 not so easy actually for him it's
somewhat uncoordinated has his position
no I wanted to no one wanted to cover
the porn t5 oh that's Queen trade let's
meet in a couple of moves it is almost
enough but not quiet just 18 points
behind and you can get 20 points for a
win if i'm not mistaken so it's not it's
not over yet
okay i went for some quick salty on the
edge I already has some pressure on the
form yeah now I can take it seven
actually next move when your piece or
not it's still very untidy disposition
yeah keep be to protected I can take a
c5 next gonna really just a piece with
Queens trader that's a that's a good
thing oh I was reading anymore I could
have taken h7 okay I have to get it
take through KJ speaking of the rook
Bishop g2 rope Tijuana wins another
piece yep yeah that that should do the
trick right I don't know if this was the
win yep if I made it I made it writer at
the end crossing the finishing line
where where is it where is it show me
the final standings yeah 235 yeah I lost
the first game and then and then made
the mid sixteen from 16 yeah thanks guys
then what's quite okay I mean the first
game was very shaky but then I got into
into a good into a good role and very
very funny I ahead two games that were
completely identical with a check made
in the middle of the board yeah I hope
you enjoyed this little video it's just
pure entertainment don't take it too
seriously and there are some people
saying okay you should do more serious
content on the channel yes I definitely
will do that and I still do I mean to do
the the Norway chess tournament for
example those chests cube videos are not
something that should be seen as instead
of other things it's just a little bonus
that that I like to do once in a while
to also enjoy myself it's just fun to
play those side tournaments okay thanks
for watching